klaus schwab who comes off as a evil  cartoon character is the head of the  world economic forum he is the main  driver of this new world order that  these people want to put in to limit  global warming replays any corporate  board directors who is unwilling to  transition to cleaner energy sources  he seems like a nice guy he says that  they should replace corporate leaders  who basically won't play along with  their climate change agenda am i not  turtley enough for the turtle club  nobody will be safe  if not everybody is vaccinated wouldn't  that imply that the vaccine doesn't work  nobody will be safe if everyone isn't  vaccinated should be no risk world  economic forum pushes space bubbles to  block out the sun so they are literally  taking a plot from the simpsons he is  pure evil